today we're talking about sustainability
the 2022 magic quadrant and tips for
retailers as we head into the holidays
I'm Sarah and welcome to this week in
Cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
at Google Cloud we're working with
global organizations to help them use
technology to build a more sustainable
future
during the 2022 United Nations climate
change conference or cop 27
representatives from countries and
organizations around the world including
Google Cloud gathered for the latest
round of climate talks
during cop27 Google Cloud published over
10 000 words across 13 posts bringing
on-site perspectives sharing customer
best practices and highlighting
Technical Solutions for climate change
you can see all of them on the blog
we're thrilled to announce that Gartner
has recognized Google Cloud's apogee as
a leader in the 2022 magic quadrant for
full lifecycle API management
the seventh time in a row we've been
recognized We believe We Are
consistently recognized for the depth of
our capabilities to help organizations
monetize their data by creating external
facing API products and providing highly
customizable developer portals in this
year's report apogee has once again
placed highest among the evaluated
vendors for our ability to execute
budget concerns and inflation shock are
causing noticeable shifts in consumer
behavior and heading into the holiday
season retailers will need to deliver
value to the increasingly cost-conscious
consumer with frictionless product
Discovery digital shopping experiences
relevant inventory and personalization
head to the blog for a full list of
pragmatic recommendations from experts
on the recent emarketer webcast
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud